hey guys how are you so today's video I
just will talk about something that
drives me absolutely nuts so I don't
really like to wear makeup but I do wear
it quite often for what I'm shooting
videos but the one thing that drives me
absolutely nuts is when you're putting
on mascara and you get it not where it
needs to be now for guys if you're not
aware of what mascara is it goes on your
eyelashes to make them bigger and fuller
and whatever else but the one thing that
you may not be aware of is how
absolutely annoying it is when you kind
of slip get it on your nose get it on
your cheek
get your forehead but the worst part is
sometimes when you're putting on mascara
and you have to sneeze you know you're
just casually just put in the middle and
just try to look so pretty and you're
just like oh sometimes it was just
swooped just I was taking everything
it's like oh you're not still over the
bottom you finally look down into the
mirror that you haven't got a single bit
of it actually on your bottom lash just
wait Twitter eyes let me just have a
little bit more of the mascara let's
start over here maybe we'll have a
better look oh gosh I'm shaky hand the
bag a shaky hand because I drank so much
coffee and it's like what is this what's
happening to me it's like I don't even
know I don't even know it just makes me
so angry
oh god it's a little better mascara is
all you need and it will go a really
long way when a hair goes up that's when
you know we mean business
thank you
hey thanks for watching guys I will see
you in my next video don't forget to
subscribe check out my last video that I
made and let me know what your number
one makeup failure do you think is I
sneezed when I put on mascara oh yeah
hey you guys you guys wanted to go to
one of her friends isn't